the message of hope and call to action
from president biden
during his first speech to a joint
session of congress last night
mr biden is calling for a big bet now on
the country's future with trillions with
a t
of dollars of new government spending
after the speech cbs news ran a snap
poll finding 85 percent of those who
watched the speech
liked what joe biden had to say in it
although an asterisk on this
we should point out slightly more than
half of those polls identified as
democrats in the first place we've got
wei xi jiang for us at the white house
covering all this wija good morning to
you
there was a lot in this speech including
some of the dangers facing the country
good morning tony and to everybody
you're absolutely right president biden
used a personal and a hopeful tone to
declare
that america is rising anew but he also
issued a warning to members of congress
that the u.s must make those investments
now
by passing his infrastructure packages
in order to compete
with countries like china that are
determined to dominate
the president of the united states
before president biden even started his
speech
he made history madam speaker
madam vice president
no president has ever said those words
from this podium for the first time two
women
flanked the president as he promised
brighter days ahead
we're working again dreaming again
discovering again and leading the world
again
in a setting unlike any before it with
pandemic safety protocols hard to miss
mr biden highlighted his accomplishments
signing a massive coven 19 relief plan
into law that included direct
payments to americans administering more
than 200 million doses of the coven 19
vaccine
and creating more than 1.3 million new
jobs more jobs in the first hundred days
than any president on record but the
president
also leveled with the american public
about the work
ahead noting that he inherited a quote
nation
in crisis the worst pandemic in a
century
the worst economic crisis since the
great depression
the worst attack on our democracy since
the civil war
it was that january 6th attack on the
capital the president said foreign
adversaries would bank on keeping
americans divided
he's betting against that they look at
the images of the mob that assaulted the
capital
as proof that the sun is sending out an
american democracy
but they're wrong you know it i know it
but we have to prove them wrong
president biden urged congress to pass a
pair of sweeping
infrastructure proposals the american
jobs plan and the american families plan
we can't be so busy competing with one
another
that we forget the competition that we
have with the rest of the world to win
the 21st century
and he pushed lawmakers to pass the
george floyd justice and policing act
by the anniversary of floyd's death next
month
congress should act should act
we have a giant opportunity to bend the
ark of the moral universe toward justice
real justice
but south carolina senator tim scott who
delivered the republican response
said his work on police reforms has been
blocked
by democrats my friends across the aisle
seem to want the issue
more than they wanted a solution but i'm
still working
i'm hopeful that this will be different
today president biden is heading to
georgia to start promoting his
american families plan which he's also
working to sell
on capitol hill next month he is
planning to host a bipartisan meeting
with the top four congressional leaders
here
and the white house says the president
is eager to meet with them in person
anthony we should thank you